uh now the the question obviously isn't
going away as to adam gase's future
it's becoming more and more of a
foregone conclusion especially if they
don't win a game this year that he'll be
gone
i'm surprised as many are that it didn't
happen during the bye week which causes
me to think maybe there's a sliver there
where joe douglas who was actually
hired with the input of adam gase finds
a way to sell
christopher and or woody johnson on
giving it a try
with trevor lawrence and gays assuming
they can get lawrence to ultimately
enter the draft and come to new york
but if gays is gone and this was
stunning to me yesterday
because boomers this would be the
equivalent chris of you and i
talking about hey you know what we think
tony dungy wants to go coach the houston
texans yeah you know what he was talking
sunday like he wants to get back into
coaching
and you know he said he really loves the
texans and he
would like he really loves deshawn
watson and he loved
that's what this is the equivalent of
when boomer assistant who works every
sunday with bill cower goes on his radio
show
yesterday morning and starts rattling
off all these reasons why he thinks
cower's ready to come back after 14
years out and why he
loves the opportunity that would be
presented by going to the jets with that
first overall pick in trevor lawrence
i was blown away by this because we just
kind of forgotten about cower as a
candidate he's been out for so long
but 14 years for him it was 15 years for
dick for meal
and vermeel came back and won a super
bowl so it's not crazy to think and joe
gibbs came back after he was in the hall
of fame
it's not crazy to think that it's at
least a possibility
especially given what boomer said well
yeah let's start there
i mean yes i i would have a hard time
thinking thinking boomer would just go
out i mean boomer's got a big mouth i
know that
okay but i'd have a hard time thinking
he just went out there and just blabbed
that away
that he might have said something to
bill cower like hey i'm gonna say this
on the radio tomorrow and i would think
bill carroll gave him the okay
or something there i would think i don't
know that but either way
i mean it's a good thought bill cower is
the type of guy
one that i sit there and think about you
know you talk about
culture change and getting an
organization on the same page and doing
that
that is the type of figure i look at
with the jets who have just not been
good for so long
i i do think it could be a positive type
of thing you know he can
get everybody to hey johnson family this
is how you run a football team come here
take notes okay
you know everybody this is how it's done
all right and then
you can lay the groundwork again to get
them back on the right track
and then the other thing you know a lot
like cleveland was for so long
the jets have been so bad for so long
it's it's appealing to coaches because
there's you can't go
down they're in the crapper they're as
down on that crapper as you can get
so everybody coaches love that aspect to
go okay wait hi
draft picks you know it's kind of a
blank canvas because the team
needs a lot of holes filled and things
like that and
expectation levels are low and they've
been low for a long long time and they
can't really go
any lower and i would imagine that
appeals to
a lot of coaches and probably a coach
like bill cower
the key to me was the quote from boomer
that bill cower
loves joe douglas because in 2008
there was talk of bill cower coaching
the jets
but he didn't love mike tannenbaum and
woody johnson was not going to push
tannenbaum out
to create an opportunity for cower to
round up some of his guys from
pittsburgh like
there was always this sense kevin
colbert and omar khan would be a couple
of guys who quickly would join
cower if he ever came back he he would
activate the bat signal from time to
time
when it looked like maybe he was
thinking about coming back that happened
a few times in the years after he
resigned from the steelers because look
he didn't retire from the steelers
i still believe to this day he knew the
steelers were never going to pay him
what he was truly worth so he was going
to resign he was going to take a few
years
and then go coach someone like
washington or someone that would pay him
big money and he'd make back
everything that he didn't make during
the time that he wasn't coaching
and then along the way he realized that
the broadcasting gig is pretty good you
make good money you don't have to worry
about wins or losses you're not obsessed
you're not stressed right it's not the
life that it is
when everything rides on whether or not
you win enough football games so
uh but but now could be the time for him
to do it
and now could be the time for him to
find a landing spot and he just makes
sense
on many levels and and again if if look
if boomer just went rogue here it's
going to be awkward
when they get together this weekend
chris i i want a full report from phil
hey yes
on the fist fight boomer could have
gotten power and boomer yeah you never
know with boomer and i say that with all
due respect because i know him very well
like
you never know he might he might have
just said hey screw you bill
i think this might happen i'm gonna
start talking about it he might have
uh but but i i would find that hard to
believe
and i understand like you know bill
cower that comment bill cower liking joe
douglas
you know joe douglas philosophically has
a pittsburgh
type mentality we want big we want
physical we want to get off the bus
and look scary and kick your butt that's
where he came from as far as baltimore
and philadelphia
that was kind of their thought process
too and those two organizations
so i could see that making sense
certainly
it'll be something if it happens and i i
i don't know whether or not the game has
passed bill cower by you know for john
gruden
who was going into team facilities every
week and interacting directly with
coaches and players
every week i think it was easier for him
to say that the
saw was still relatively sharp when
you're in a studio and removed from that
for 14 years
it becomes a little bit harder to get
back on the horse and you better be
ready to surround yourself with people
who
have been doing it more recently because
you've got some some relearning
and new learning to do that's right when
you haven't coached for that long you're
right there is there's going to be some
of that
but yes it's going to be about him
hiring and bill cower
he's an overseer you know he is one of
those type of guys
where he might not yeah it might not be
into every x's to know and this scheme
and that scheme and blah blah blah but
he's going to be able to walk into the
coaches meeting and go
wait we can't run that defense this week
against this passing offense that's
stupid
that's ludicrous we got to do something
else here because this quarterback and
those receivers will carve us up
and then you know he can he can walk
into the offensive side of the ball and
go
we can't protect and do this protection
against this defensive line you know so
that's where
you know again it doesn't concern me so
much that he hasn't been around because
he's kind of that type of coach
anyways he's an overseer let's tie this
together
this is the proper way for us to play on
this side of the ball this is the proper
way on this side of the ball
and now let's make it cohesive and work
and uh
i i think he could do it you know i
think he's been paying attention to the
sport and been all over it either way
to where i don't think it would be a
huge transition for a guy like bill
cower
and one last point before we take a
break coaches who have won a super bowl
with one team are keenly
aware of the fact that no one
has won a super bowl with two different
teams
they are keenly aware of that and they
all would love to be
the first one that's crazy do it and
cower would have the opportunity
to do it especially if trevor lawrence
ends up being the guy that everyone
thinks he'll be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports